- You had to make a Wakanda Forever
without Chadwick Boseman.
- Yeah.
- So did the cast, was
it kinda odd at first?
Did y'all do anything?
- Oh, when we arrived in ya know,
on the set, ya know, a
couple of days before,
you know, reading through
and rehearsals and stuff,
it was planned.
The producers and director had planned,
had rented a plane and we
all flew to South Carolina
and we went to visit
together, his resting place,
together.
- Wow.
- And it was a beautiful day.
His uncles were there, his cousin,
and we just, you know,
just spoke from our heart
about him, how we felt about him
or times with him.
- Yeah.
- You know and that was
really, really lovely,
a great way to just begin because ya know,
we miss him terribly.
And then when we got to the set,
it was like okay, we've had this moment
of coming together and now,
we've got to come to work
and that's what he would
want for us. We know that!
- I know but it feels like the movie.
It feels like that's something
you would've done in Wakanda.
Like if someone passed,
you know what I'm saying?
Like it feels, I'm such a fan, sorry.
Keeping my cool.
I'm like really excited
about the new movie.